hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of book seven of his Nicomachean ethics
Aristotle engages in some interesting
but rather short discussions that bear
upon the nature and the value of
pleasure or rather pleasures because
he's going to distinguish between
different kinds of pleasure and
different ways in which something that's
that's Pleasant
might be seen to be something good and
were seen to be something bad
and one of the issues that he is dealing
with early on in that discussion it is
this this suspicion or this distrust
that many people have a pleasure purse a
pleasure in general as being something
bad so the idea is well look if you're
getting something Pleasant out of it
it's probably if it's not bad by itself
it certainly isn't good because goodness
is something fundamentally different
than say just the pleasant and this is
an idea that runs through a lot of
different moral systems Aristotle
himself is not going to say that all
pleasures are by virtue of being pledged
pleasure or Pleasant necessarily good
there's there some
that are quite problematic as as we're
going to see but if he does want to say
that is this distrust of pleasure per se
it is actually a misplaced and he gives
several different arguments or you might
say discussions of why this is the case
and put the four most interesting ones
here you sort of fires them off one
after the other so one of the things
that we want to keep in mind is a
distinction and this is a distinction
that we can make in a more Universal
sense between saying something is
something else in an absolute way and
then saying that it is so in a
accidental way or per se as opposed the
first one to be per se as opposed to in
relation to something right in this case
what would he's talking about in terms
he's using our hot lows which means
simply and teeny with respect to a
particular person or with respect to
somebody right but we could think of
this more broadly as you know saying
something is it is a certain way
absolutely and then being so in a
qualified ways is often how we talk
about it so whenever something says that
we need to keep in mind that good is
said in multiple ways and among those
multiple ways is this fundamental
distinction between saying that
something is good in itself good simply
or absolutely without qualification for
instance air--so thinks that something
along those lines would be mine news
right we can also say that virtue is
something that is good in itself we can
say that happiness rightly conceived
eudaimonia
is something along those lines as well
and then we have something being good
for someone teaming in in Greek I'm
coming from the you know data 40s right
good the in relation to one particular
so if we consider diet for example I am
an omnivore I eat just about everything
within reason of course I try to stay
away from too much processed food things
like that yeah and there are things that
are good for me to eat that are not good
for somebody who is you know not quite
as healthy as me horizont restrict diet
or is doing some you know some other
thing that that requires them to eat a
certain sort of food stuffs right let's
take meat for example and then put aside
the worries about you know Ethical
Treatment of Animals we're not we're not
gonna start them staying in terms of
pure health if I don't need a lot of
meat but I eat some meat that can be
good hurt for me whereas it might not be
good for somebody else there's all sorts
of things along those lines
there are many things that are good for
one person but not good for another
person and that doesn't mean that
they're no longer good it just means
that we have to be realistic in how
we're using this term good so how does
it apply it pleasure them well there are
some pleasures that are in fact good
absolutely Aristotle would say although
even even the ones that he tends to use
as examples a little bit later he'll say
even contemplation can sometimes go
wrong you know so but in general we can
say that there are some things that are
you know what he calls the natural
pleasures good absolutely there's a lot
of pleasures that are good but they're
only good within certain contexts so you
know to take a certain classic example
joking around right why does Aristotle I
actually have a virtue of good humor in
a tropical ale well it's because
something that is good idea which is
enjoying joking around is not good in
every single context and the person who
is excessive jokes around all the time
even when it's inappropriate like you
know say telling bawdy jokes about
somebody
funeral bad idea right it could be good
to do that in another context but it's
not good in that context so that's an
important distinction that Aristotle
makes that he's got this interesting
discussion about restorative pleasures
and what does he mean by restorative
pleasures these are the pleasures that
come about when we are in a bodily state
where we we are desiring something
because we actually need it like hunger
for example when we're hungry we enjoy
eating and there's actually quite a few
dishes that people don't particularly
enjoy eating if they're in healthy
condition when they're no longer hungry
then the the foods kind of insipid to
them but when they're hungry they're
like oh man this is the best stuff
there's there's that same hunger is the
best sauce right drinking you know think
about how how good water tastes even the
water really doesn't have any taste when
you're coming in from doing yard work on
a hot day all sorts of other pleasures
like that aerosol doesn't talk about
sleeping in terms of restorative
pleasure but I think that we could think
about it that way particularly you know
as you get older sleep deprivation tends
to produce pains in the bottom right so
restorative pleasures I have to do with
putting the body back in good condition
and typically there's a pain that's
associated with the lack and the
pleasure comes in and sort of you know
substitutes for the pain Aristotle says
that that restorative pleasures are not
actually in themselves Pleasant that
they are only accidentally Pleasant only
in relation to if we want to use this
distinction again only in relation to
certain contexts only in relation to
certain people it's possible to go
totally wrong with them right to become
somebody who is a such a glutton that
they have to eat all the time and they
need to feel that we're sort of pleasure
but Aristotle wouldn't call
you know a thing - all right your your
deforming nature in that case so he says
here we go the activity of desire is
this activity of the part of us which is
remained in the natural state and there
are some pleasures which don't
necessarily involve pain or desire at
all like the desire contemplation those
would be the opposite in a certain
respect restorative pleasures
restorative pleasures are in a certain
respect sort of pleasures light not that
quite pleasures as as such although he
does know a little bit later on that
because we have so much experience with
bodily pleasures we tend to think of
these as the paradigm for pleasure now
another thing that he says is that it's
really really interesting it touches on
a very important wide-ranging doctrine
in Aristotle is this remark that's that
people will say you know some pleasant
things are harmful and we could have
other modalities to it as well like
perhaps some of them are unjust or base
they're ice phone the opposite of the
Cologne right so what he's talking about
there is good in something being good or
not being good in a general sense either
phone or kakoen in Greek Aristotle
distinguishes between different
modalities if you want to call it that
or ways of eating something good and
these are what we call ranges of moral
values so some things are good precisely
because they are useful or they're bad
because they're harmful so for example
medicine is good because it's useful for
the body right back in the day medicine
tasted pretty terrible for the most part
and so that's an example something that
is good for you in being useful baking
beneficial but I'm not good at the sense
of being pleasant being actually
unpleasant
some things that are actually Pleasant
for us may be harmful for the body or
they could be harmful for for other
things as well
you know the pocketbook our reputation
although there we start getting into the
base another realm of that is the just
and the unjust you know and then we have
this this wide range of the the fine and
the foul or if you like the beautiful
the ugly the noble of the base that is
signified in greek by the Kalon and the
I scroll and so point out that pleasure
is not always something good in every
other respect Aristotle says yeah that's
fine it still is good as pleasure it's
just not good as being something harmful
it's actually bad as being something
harmful it's bad as being something
unjust it's bad as being something based
but considered just as pleasure it is
something good that's part of why we're
actually tempted by it then attracted
it's that that pleasure by itself is bad
it's rather than it's not the fullness
of possible good necessary he also says
so what you know we could say the same
thing about other manners she says was a
great quip here to argue that pleasures
are bad because some Pleasant things are
detrimental to health is the same thing
as to argue that health is bad because
some healthy things are bad for the
pockets right so you know we have to
trade off good innocence sometimes and
prioritize which type of goodness we're
going to go for that doesn't mean that
pleasure is bad because of that it just
means it's not entirely good another
interesting argument that he provides is
this this notion he says look pain the
opposite of pleasure
lupe and Greek is something bad and it
can be understood as being bad in
multiple ways in some cases pain is
ban by itself it's not something that
it's actually the opposite death the
painful is one a variety of the band can
also be bad by impeding activity you
know so for example I have four yeah
probably close to 15 years now suffered
from some arthritis and this is sort of
classic example right it's what if what
does arthritis consistent its pain in
the joints and then the things around
the joints and and you know there's kind
of an interesting self reinforcing
dynamic to it because when you feel
arthritic you you don't want to do a lot
of activity that you normally would
digging I want to go take walks you
don't want to exercise you don't want to
sometimes do anything but lay in bed
right but what's what's the best thing
for you it's to actually stay mobile and
keep moving those joints around and you
will indeed feel a bit better arthritis
is a form of pain that impedes natural
activities of the human body we can talk
about all sorts of other kinds of pain
that would be bad because they interfere
with our normal activities in other ways
or are they they interfere with
activities that are you might say to our
improvement activities that are leading
us to something better so you know if
you find it painful to study you're
going to have a hard time studying all
right Plato talks about that in the
Republic if you really don't if you find
exercise boring and I suppose boring
could be a modality of pain then it's
going to be difficult for you to
exercise you know we can go on and on
about that but now here's the upshot if
pain is something that whether it's bad
just absolutely or bad in a certain
respect doesn't that look like this
right here it sure does yeah and we
should suspect that that sense pleasure
is the opposite of pain if pain is bad
pleasure as pleasure must be something
good
perhaps only good in
respect to certain people but something
good nonetheless